a while back we were talking about the
stop button problem right you have this
you have this it's kind of a toy problem
in a high safety you have an artificial
general intelligence in a robot it wants
something you know it wants to make you
a cup of tea or whatever you put a big
red stop button on it and you want to
set it up so that it behaves courage'
bleah that it will allow you to hit the
button it won't hit the button itself
you know and it won't try and prevent
you this sort of behaving in a in a
sensible way in a safe way and that like
by default most AGI designs will not
behave this way well we left it as an
open problem right and it kind of still
is an open problem but there have been
some really interesting things proposed
as possible solutions or approaches to
take and I wanted to talk about
cooperative inverse reinforcement
learning
I thought the easiest way to explain
cooperative inverse reinforcement
learning is to build a tower backwards
right learning we know like machine
learning and reinforcement learning is
an area of machine learning I guess you
could call it it's it's kind of a it's a
way of presenting a problem in most
machine learning the kind of thing that
people have talked about already a lot
on computer file thinking of ovals
videos and the related ones usually you
get in some data and then you're trying
to do something with that like classify
you know unseen things or you're trying
to do like regression to find out what
value something would have for certain
inputs that kind of thing whereas
reinforcement learning the idea is you
have an agent in an environment and
you're trying to find a policy but so so
there were at the backup what do we mean
by an agent it's an entity that
interacts with its environment to try
and achieve something effectively doing
things in an environment so this isn't
necessary is this a physical thing or is
it doesn't have to be so if you have a
robot in a room then you can model
as the robot being an agent and the rim
being the environment similarly if you
have a computer game like pac-man
then pac-man is an agent and the sort of
make it easy mrs. environment so let's
stick with pac-man net the way that a
reinforcement learning framework for
dealing with pac-man is you say okay
you've got pac-man here's the agent is
in the environment and you have actions
the pac-man can take in the environment
now it's kind of neat in pac-man there
are always exactly four actions you can
take or well I guess five you can sit
there and do nothing you can move up
left right or down you don't always have
all of those options like sometimes
there's a wall and you can't move right
but those are the only that's the that's
the complete set of actions that you
have and then you have the environment
contains sort of dots that you can pick
up which are they give you points it's
got these ghosts that chase you that you
don't want to touch and I think there's
also there's like tails you can pick up
that make the ghost edible and then you
chase them down the stuff anyway so the
difference in reinforcement learning is
that the agent is in the environment and
it learns by interacting with the
environment is and so it's kind of close
to the way that animals learn and the
way the humans learn you try you try
doing something you know I'm going to
try you know touching this fire oh that
hurt
so that's act caused me like a negative
reward that's caused me a pain signal
which is something I don't want so I
learn to avoid doing things like
touching a fire so in in a pacman
environment you might you might sort of
say if you're in if you're in a
situation like let's draw pac-man let's
say he's an amazed like this you look at
pac-man's options he told her left
he can't go right he can go up and if he
goes up he'll get a dot which earns you
some points so up gets a score of you
know +10 whereof you've decided it oh
well whatever the score is in the game
either way or if he goes down he'll be
immediately go by this ghost the point
is that pac-man doesn't need to be aware
of the entire
right the entire maze you can just feed
in a fairly small amount of information
about its immediate environment which is
the same thing as if you have a robot in
a room it can't it doesn't know
everything about the whole room it can
only see what it sees through its camera
you know it has sensors they give it
some some information about the
environment partial information I
suppose just playing devil's advocate
the difference here is you usually Pat
mine as being controlled by a human who
can't see the whole board so the point
being if that Ghost is actually not
static and is chasing pac-man and he's
heading up to get that pill if if a few
pixels later that that corridor if you
like stops in a dead-end yep well he's
kind of stuff neither way really that's
true yeah so that is because so so the
most well yeah almost every
reinforcement learning algorithm almost
everything that tries to deal with this
problem doesn't just look at the
immediate surroundings or it looks at
the immediate surroundings but it also
looks a certain distance in time so
you're not just saying what's going to
happen next frame but so like if you go
down here most algorithms would say okay
the option is going down in this
situation is bad but also all of the
options we chose in all of the
situations that we were in in the last
second or two also get a little bit this
is kind of a decay there's time time
discounting so that you're not just
punishing the immediate thing that
causes the negative reward but also the
decisions you make leading up to it so
that pac-man might learn not to get
himself stuck in corners as well as just
learning not to run straight into ghosts
so that's the basics of reinforcement
learning there's different algorithms
that do it and the idea is you you
actually you start off exploring the
environment just at random you just pick
completely random actions and then as
those actions start having consequences
for you and you start getting rewards
and punishments you start to learn
which actions are better to use in which
situations does that mean in part man's
case would learn the maze or would it
just learn the back to sources it
depends on what algorithm you're using
very sophisticated one might learn the
whole maze a simpler one might just
learn a more kind of local policy but
the point is yeah you learn you learn a
kind of mapping between or a function
that takes in the situation you're in
and outputs a good action to take
there's also kind of an interesting
trade-off there which I think we may
have talked about before about
exploration versus exploitation in that
you want your agent to be generally
taking good actions but you don't want
it to always take the action that it
thinks is best right now because it's
understanding maybe being complete and
then it just kind of gets stuck right it
never finds out anything it never finds
out anything about other options that it
could have gone with because as soon as
it did something that kind of worked it
just goes with that forever so a lot of
these systems build in some sub variants
some randomness awesome right exactly
like you usually do the thing you think
is best but some small percentage of the
time you just try something random
anyway and you can change that over time
like a lot of algorithms as as the
policy gets more and more as they learn
more and more they start doing random
stuff less and less that kind of thing
so that's the like absolute basics of
reinforcement learning and how it works
and it's really really powerful like
especially when you combine it with deep
neural networks as the thing that's
doing the learning
like deep mind did this really amazing
thing where I think they were playing
pacman they were playing a bunch of
different Atari games and the thing
that's cool about it is all they told
the system was here's what's on the
screen and here's the score of the game
make the score be dig this score is your
reward right that's it and it learned
all of the specific dynamics of the game
and generally achieved top level
and also the human play the next word is
going to be in verse we did a thing with
a veil on anti learning but can't work
all the time that sort of thing right
yeah this is not like that this is a
description of a different type of
problem it's a totally different problem
that they call inverse because in
reinforcement learning you have a reward
function that determines when you want
situations you get rewards in and you're
in your environment with your reward
function and you're trying to find the
appropriate actions to take that
maximize that reward in inverse
reinforcement learning you're not in the
environment at all you're watching an
expert so you've got the video of the
world championship record pac-man player
right and you have all of that all of
that information you can see so you're
saying rather than rather than having
the reward function and trying to figure
out the actions you can see the actions
and you're trying to figure out the
reward function
so it's inverse because you're kind of
solving the reverse of the problem
you're not trying to maximize a reward
by choosing actions you're looking at
actions and trying to figure out what
for what they're maximizing so that's
really useful because it lets you sort
of learn by observing experts so coming
back to AI safety you might think that
this would be kind of useful from an AI
safety perspective you know you have
this problem the core problem of AI
safety or one of the core problems of AI
safety is how do you make sure the AI
wants what we want we can't reliably
specify what it is we want so and if we
create something very intelligent that
wants something else that's something
else is what's probably going to happen
even if we don't want that to happen how
do we make a system that reliably wants
the same thing we want so you can see
how inverse reinforcement learning might
be kind of attractive here because you
might have a system that watches humans
doing things and tries to figure out you
know if we are experts
humans it's trying to figure out what
rewards we're maximizing and try and
sort of formalized in its in its
understanding what it is we want by
observing us that's pretty cool but yeah
it has some problems one problem is that
we don't in inverse reinforcement
learning there's this assumption of
optimality that the person that the
agent you're watching is an expert and
they do an optimal play and you're you
know there is some clear coherent thing
like the score the Dare optimizing and
the assumption of the the algorithms
that do this is that the way the world
champion plays is the best possible way
and that assumption is obviously never
quite true or generally not quite true
but it works well enough you know but
humans are not like human behavior is
not actually really optimizing to get
more humans one perfectly in ways places
where that assumption isn't true could
cause problems so is this where
cooperative comes in because when we
started doing it backwards whose
co-operative inverse reinforcement
learning on right so you could imagine a
situation where you have the robot you
have the AGI it watches people doing
their thing uses inverse reinforcement
learning to try and figure out the
things you menses how you try and figure
out the things you value and then adopt
those values as if though right
the most obvious like the first problem
is we don't actually want to create
something that values the same thing as
humans like if it observes that I you
know I want a cup of tea
we want it to want me to have a cup of
tea we don't want it to want a cup of
tea but that's like it that's quite easy
to fix you just say you know figure out
what the value
and then optimize it for the humans so
these it affects but you don't amoenus
that's doable but then the other thing
is if you're if you're trying to teach
if you're actually trying to use this to
teach a robot to do something it turns
out to not be very efficient like if you
works with pac-man if you want to learn
how to be good at pac-man you probably
want to not just watch the world's best
pac-man player and try to copy them
right that's not like an efficient way
to learn because there might be a
situation where you you're thinking what
do I do if I find myself stuck in this
corner of the maze or whatever and the
pros never get stuck there so you have
no you have no example of what to do
well all the pro or watching the pros
can teach you is don't get stuck there
and then once you're there you've gotta
know you've gotta hope let's say I
wanted to teach my room or to make me a
cup of tea I go into the kitchen and I
show it how I make a cup of tea I would
probably have to do that a lot of times
to actually get the all the information
across because and you'll notice this is
not how people teach right if you were
teaching a person how to make a cup of
tea you might do something like if
there's some difficult stage of the
process you might show you might do one
demonstration but show that one stage
like three times so usually do it like
this let me show you that again and then
if you're using inverse reinforcement
learning the system believes that you
are playing optimally right so it thinks
that doing it three times is somehow
necessary and it's trying to figure out
what values like what rewards you must
be optimizing that doing it three times
is important so that's the problem right
that's where the assumption isn't true
or you might want to say okay what you
do is you get the tea out of the box
here and you put it in the thing but if
there's none in this box you go over to
this cupboard where we keep the backup
supplies and you open a new box
right but you can't show that the only
way that the only way that the robot can
learn to go and get the extra supplies
only when this one has run out is if you
were in a situation where that would be
optimal place that the thing has to be
actually run out in order for you to
demonstrate that you can't say if the
situation were different from how it is
then you should go and do this so the
other thing you might want if you're
trying to teach things efficiently you
might want the AI to be taking an active
role in the learning process right you
kind of want it to be like if there's if
there's some aspect of it that it
doesn't understand you don't want it
just sitting there observing you
optimally do the thing and they're
trying to copy if there's something that
it didn't see you kind of wanted to be
able to say I hang on I didn't see that
you know or I'm confused about this or
maybe ask you a terrifying question or
just in general like communicate with
you and cooperate with you in the
learning process so yeah so the way that
the way that cooperative inverse
reinforcement learning works is it's a
way of setting up the rewards such that
these types of behaviors hopefully will
be incentivized and should come out
automatically if you're optimizing you
know if the AI is doing well so what you
do is you specify the interaction as a
cooperative game where the robots reward
function is the humans reward function
but the robot doesn't know that reward
function at all it never knows the
reward that it gets and it never knows
the function that generates the reward
did it gets it just knows that it's the
same as the humans so it's trying to
optimize it's trying to maximize the
reward it gets but the only clues it has
for what it needs to do to maximize its
own reward is observing the human and
trying to figure out what the human is
trying to maximize this is a bit like
two players on the ice game but you can
only see one school yeah like if you're
you're you're both on the same team
yeah but only the human knows the rules
of the game effectively we both want you
both get the same reward so you both
want the same thing just kind of by
definition but the process so in a sense
you've kind of just defined the core
problem of though saying that the core
problem one of the core problems of AI
safety is how do you make sure that the
robot wants what the human ones
and in this case you've just specified
it usually you couldn't do that because
we don't really know what the human
wants either to people who don't speak
the same language can still communicate
with actions and gestures and things
yeah and you can generally get the gist
as the idea across to the other person
is a bit like that yeah but a
sufficiently sophisticated agent if you
have an AGI that could be quite powerful
it can speak you know and it can
understand language and everything else
and it knows that this so it knows for
example hopefully it should be able to
figure out that when the human is
showing something three times that it's
that the human is doing that in order to
communicate information and not because
it's the optimal way to do it
because it knows that the human knows
there's a kind of there's common
knowledge of what's going on in this in
the scenario so it allows for situations
where the human is just demonstrating
something or explaining something or it
allows the AI to ask about things that
it's unclear about it because
everybody's on the same team trying to
achieve the same thing in principle so
the point is if you have a big red stop
button in this scenario the AI is not
incentivized to disable or ignore that
stop button because he constitutes
important information about its reward
right the AI is desperately trying to
maximize a reward function that it
doesn't know and so if it observes the
human trying to hit the stop button that
provides really strong information that
what it's doing right now
is not going to maximize the humans
award which means is not going to
maximize its own reward so it wants to
allow itself to be shut off if the human
wants to shut it off because it's for
its own good
so this is this is a clever way of
aligning its interests with ours right
right it's not so it's so like the
problem in the in the default situation
is I've told it to get a cup of tea and
it's going to do that whatever else I do
and if I try to turn it off it's not
going to let me because that will stop
it from getting your cup of tea whereas
in this situation the fact that I want a
cup of tea is something it's not
completely sure of and so it doesn't
think it knows better than me so when I
go to hit that stop button it thinks oh
I thought I was supposed to be going
over here and getting a cup of tea and
running over this baby or whatever but
the fact that he's rushing to hit the
button means I must have gotten
something wrong so I'd better stop and
learn more about this situation because
I'm at risk of losing a bunch of reward
so yeah it seems like it seems like a
potentially workable thing a workable
approach so one interesting thing about
this is there is still an assumption
that the humans behavior is in
accordance with some utility function or
some reward function some objective
function like if the human Bayes very
irrationally that can cause problems for
their system because the whole thing
revolves around the fact that the robot
is not completely confident of what its
reward is it's got a model of its of
what the reward function is like that
it's constantly updating as it learns
and it doesn't have full confidence and
it's using the human as the source of
information so fundamentally you have
robot
believes that the human knows better
than it does how to maximize the humans
reward so in situations where that's not
true like if you run this for long
enough and the
robot managed to build up a really
really high level of confidence in what
it thinks the human reward function is
then it might ignore it stop button
later on if it thinks that it knows
better than the human what you think at
once which sounds very scary but might
actually be what you want to happen like
if you imagine you know it's the future
and we've got these robots and they all
have a big red stop button on them in
they're all here and everything's
wonderful
and you say to your robot Oh take my my
four-year-old son to school you know
drive him to school in the car because
it's a 1950s sci-fi future we're not
self-driving cars it's like robots in
cars anyway and it's it's driving this
kid to school it's doing 70 on the
motorway and the kid sees the big red
shiny button and smacks it right in
principle the human has just pressed the
button and a lot of designs for a button
would just say a human is hit your
button you have to stop whereas this
design might say I have been around for
a long time I've learned a lot about
what human value and also I observe that
this specific human does not reliably
behave in its own best interests so
maybe this hitting the button is not
communicating to me information about
what this human really wants they're
just hitting it because it's a big red
button and I should not shut myself off
so it has the potential to be safer than
a button that always works but it's a
little bit unsettling that you might end
up with systems that sometimes actually
do ignore the shutdown command because
they think they know better
it's looking at right now as it says
button gets hit I get zero reward button
doesn't get hit if I manage to stop them
then I get the cup of tea
I get like maximum reward if you give
some sort of compensation